I'm so glad you've joined us so first
for life on the go we design the world's
best camera and put it in the world's
most helpful phone introducing the
beautiful new pixel 3 the new pixel
comes in to display sizes the five and a
half inch pixel 3 and the 6 point 3 inch
pixel three XL our front firing stereo
speakers are 40% louder and richer than
last year
perfect for a video call or for playing
music by the pool when we introduce zero
shutter lag hdr+ in the first pixel it
blew away traditional HDR methods and
we're still the only ones to use this
method when you press the shutter pixel
captures a burst of short several short
exposures we combine the images
algorithmically to create an image that
is brighter more detailed and more
colorful
this technology is generations ahead of
other smartphones top shot automatically
captures alternate shots in HDR plus so
your timing wasn't perfect it will
suggest a better one you can also scroll
through the alternates and save one of
those instead and then there's super
resume instead of shooting a grainy
photo pixel three shoots a burst of
photos each a bit different taking
advantage of the natural tiny movements
of your hand you can guess what happens
next
you run the variations through a merging
algorithm to create a beautiful zoomed
in shot nice sight works so well you'll
never use your flash again let's take a
look these shots are completely
untouched night sight makes pixel the
best low-light smartphone camera we
added a second camera on the front that
captures a hundred and eighty four
percent more of the scene than iPhone
10s now you can fit everyone in the shot
without a selfie stick or unusually long
arms like mine just zoom out the
difference is striking we've evolved a
are stickers to what we now call
playground and both sit into both the
front and rear cameras characters can
now also respond to your actions and
facial expressions they look like
they're really in the scene with you for
even more playful though
photos and videos this year we
integrated google lens directly into the
pixel 3 camera pointed at a takeout menu
and lens will pull out the phone number
to call point at a movie poster to click
through to the URL there are a lot of
brilliant new superpowers coming in
pixel 3s camera so here's a quick list
of some of the other features you'll see
in our demo area later photo booth mode
automatically snaps photos with a smile
or when you make a funny face
no shutter button needed with motion
autofocus just tap on people puppies or
anything else that won't coastal and
they'll stay in focus as they move
around the frame we made a few
enhancements the portrait mode you can
edit the depth of field in a portrait
you can also change the focal subject of
the photo or make the color pop and one
of the best aspects of pixel 3 is free
unlimited storage at original quality
you'll never have to worry about storing
syncing or finding your photos when you
get that call and you can't or don't
want to pick up just tap the screen call
button and your phone will answer for
you and ask who's calling and why as you
can see here the conversation is
transcribed in real-time on your screen
you can decide whether to pick up Sena
quick reply or mark the cost BAM you'll
never have to talk to another
telemarketer and we all know what it's
like to be overwhelmed by notifications
so we've developed a feature we call
flip to shush an easy gesture to
minimize distractions just turn your
phone upside down on the table your
pixel will take the hint and mute sounds
and notifications so you can have a
quiet dinner with friends or spend some
time with your family we're excited to
introduce the smartest wireless charger
ever the new pixel Stan pixel son isn't
just a charger it changes the way you
interact with your phone thanks to the
Google assistant when you dock your
phone the UI
adjusts to be easily glanceable from
across the room you can control it with
your voice or the one touch of
suggestions on the display pixel 3 is
available for pre-order now starting at
$7.99 and pixel stand is $79 pixel 3
will
on October 18th in the US through
Verizon and unlocked on the Google store
and project by Google pixel slate is a
completely new experience giving you
powerful productivity in a fresh mobile
form something that isn't a laptop
trying to be a tablet because we wants a
fan of their tablet or a tablet that's
really a phone pretending to be a
computer instead we combine the helpful
elements of all of these devices to
create a modern computing experience
people have been asking for we design
pixel slate to be both thin and light
it's crafted with beautiful lines and
rounded edges in a stylish midnight blue
it has a perfectly balanced center of
gravity so it's incredibly comfortable
to hold pixel slate is engineered with a
stunning detailed display so sitting
back to enjoy a movie is better than
ever
it has 293 pixels per inch that's 6
million pixels for the sharpest picture
in the category to get to this level of
quality pixel slate uses a custom
display with low-temperature
polycrystalline silicon technology which
allows for a hundred times faster
movement of electrons versus a standard
display as a result you can efficiently
light up a massive number of pixels your
movies photos and games will be stunning
in vibrant colors and brilliant
resolution now a brilliant display
doesn't mean much without great sound so
with pixel slate we've positioned the
speakers on the front of the device so
they can direct stereo sound towards you
instead of out towards the walls or the
floor it's also a great device for cord
cutters and nothing brings us to life
better than YouTube TV we're excited to
give you three months of YouTube TV with
the purchase of a new pixel slate or
pixel book so you get live TV for more
than 60 networks including sports and
local news we've also designed the
front-facing camera to be perfect for
video chat it has a wide-angle lens so
you can fit every
the frame in a sensor with larger pixels
which allows for excellent low-light
performance pixel slate represents a new
chapter for Chrome OS the UI is now
optimized to be simple and easy to use
on a touchscreen it's a Chrome OS
experience that's meant to be held in
your hands and at the same time it gives
you a full desktop experience not one
designed for a phone you can work the
way that you're used to working you can
even run developer tools and full
powered Linux applications check out the
reconfigured launcher instead of hunting
for the app you need machine learning
customizes the launcher just for you
suggesting the apps that you're most
likely looking for it's your own
personal Google right at your fingertips
and now with pixel slate the Google
assistant is even more deeply integrated
within Chrome OS simply use your voice
and the assistant can help you find a
restaurant dictate an email or play your
favorite show pixel slate also includes
a tightened security chip so your
information device passwords and
operating system are protected on your
device and to eliminate the fuss of
typing your password pixel slates power
button doubles as a fingerprint sensor
so you can unlock it just as quickly and
securely as you do your pixel phone but
a true desktop experience demands a
great keyboard so we created the pixel
slate keyboard the keyboard connects to
pixel slate in a snap no pairing or
charging needed just connect it and
start typing it's full size backlit
keyboard is incredibly comfortable to
type on the rounded hush keys are soft
and quiet so you hope you've that person
with a loud clackety keyboard the folio
is infinitely adjustable so you can
comfortably use it at any angle you'd
like pixel slate comes in several
configurations starting at $5.99 pixel
slate keyboard is $1.99 and pixel book
pen is $99
[Music]
with google onhub we've redesigned
google's most helpful services like
search youtube maps calendar and photos
so they're easily controllable with your
voice and provide glanceable help we
obsessed about what a display designed
specifically for your home should do the
elegant floating display is big enough
so that you can see things even from
across the room but it's small enough to
fit in any space in your home
we also consciously did not put a camera
on hub so that it was comfortable to use
in the private spaces of your home like
your bedroom we made sure that hub can
respond automatically to the ambient
light in the room to do this we
developed a feature called ambient EQ
with ambient EQ we take a dedicated
sensor and combined it with our own
imaging algorithms so that we can
fine-tune the brightness and color of
the display so now hub can respond
automatically to the bright white tones
of natural light that you get during the
day and then gradually shift into the
oranges and yellows of your indoor
lights in the evening we want to build a
thoughtful home for our users and where
this comes to life the most is in how
easy it is with hub to set up manage and
control your devices you can even see
the state of your entire home at a
glance with hub we're introducing home
view with the swipe down from the top of
the screen you can bring up a simple
dashboard the dashboard shows you the
state of your entire home at a quick
glance and provides you quick access to
all your devices home view was designed
to be super easy and intuitive to use
with a simple tap or with your voice you
can even see things by room so you can
turn down the temperature in the bedroom
and turn up the music in the living room
it's now all in one place for the very
first time and easily accessible by
everyone and your family and we're
providing the same level of control even
if you're not near your hub we've
redesigned the Google map to be the
mobile controller for your smart home it
has the same
home view - borders hub so now you can
control all your devices from any phone
even when you're not at home now with
nest devices we have all the tools in
place to help take the experience of a
thoughtful home to the very next level
so we made sure that hub was deeply
integrated with nest devices like nest
camera nest thermostat and even hello
doorbell so for instance if you're
having dinner and someone happens during
your doorbell hub will automatically
show you is at the front door and you
can tap a quick response or use your
voice to let your guests know that
you'll be right there we use machine
learning to only show your best photos
on hub we automatically filter out
blurry photos underexposed photos those
random pictures of things like receipts
and even duplicate photos you can
pre-order Google home hub on the Google
store today for a hundred and forty nine
dollars and it's also available on
October 22nd at retail locations here in
the US UK and Australia made by Google
devices empower people to do more with
their day so they have to do less with
their tap and they can focus on what
matters most really appreciate you being
here with us today thank you have a
great day
[Applause]